ja in meinem Vortrag soll es jetzt auch
um Zeit gehen aber diesmal vor allem aus
einer philosophischen Perspektive also
ein bisschen komplementär zu der
Chronobiologie und ich bin gespannt ob
sich darin auch einige nähen ergeben der
Titel ist Zeit der Bildung Untertitel
Sukzession und Evolution von leeren und
lernen was es damit auf sich hat mit der
Sukzession und der Evolution werde ich
gleich noch genauer zeigen hier noch
kurz die Gliederung ich möchte mit dem
Problem
anfangen was das Verhältnis von Zeit und
Bildung betrifft also wie müssen wir
Bildung verstehen wenn wir sie unter dem
zeitlichen Gesichtspunkt betrachten das
setzt natürlich voraus dass wir erstmal
uns überlegen müssen was ist Zeit das
ist natürlich eine große Frage für die
im Rahmen dieses kurzen Vortrags nicht
genug Zeit
da ist und wir müssen ganz kurz auch auf
den Begriff der Bildung schauen auch das
kann man natürlich im Rahmen der kurzen
Zeit nicht erschöpfen behandeln aber mir
geht's auch hier nur um Perspektiven und
gar nicht um was erschöpfend ist und
Impuls und abschließen möchte ich
schauen wie sich dieses philosophische
Verhältnis von Zeit und Bildung auch auf
die konkrete Praxis im Lehrer und lernen
übertragen lässt
ja zur Problemstellung wie verhalten
sich Zeit und Bildung zueinander welche
zeitliche Struktur besitzt Bildung kann
man weiter Fragen hat Bildung ein
zeitlichen Anfang und ein zeitliches
Ende also ist es so eine zeitstrecke die
die Bildung charakterisiert ist das
adäquat und dann die Frage wie können
wir Zeitlichkeit bewusst für Bildung und
darunter verstehe jetzt eben auch Lehre
und Forschung nutzen also wie können
unser Zeit Verständnis wenn wir den
Zeitbegriff philosophischen mal geklärt
haben ganz bewusst auch einsetzen das
setzt jetzt natürlich voraus dass wir
erstmal bestimmen was es Zeit und da
möchte ich ganz
gleich mitten in die Sache eingehen
nämlich ein Zitat bringt vom spät
antiken Philosophen Augustinus sie hat
nämlich eine ganz zentrale Frage
aufgeworfen er ist einer der ersten
wirklichen zeitphilosophen ich lese es
jetzt mal kurz vor was sie da gesagt hat
was also ist die Zeit wenn niemand mich
danach fragt weiß ich es wenn ich es
einem fragenden erklären will weiß ich
es nicht trotzdem behaupte ich fest zu
wissen dass es keine vergangene Zeit
gebe wenn nichts vorübergehe keine
künftige Zeit wenn ich zeranke und keine
gegenwärtige Zeit wenn es nichts gäbe
das da ist wie kommt also jenen zwei
Zeiten der vergangenen und der
zukünftigen sein zu der einerseits des
vergangen nicht mehr ist und
andererseits das zukünftige noch nicht
ist es ist so die erste wirkliche
Problematisierung der Zeit und ich
glaube jeder kann das nachvollziehen es
ist seltsam mit der Zeit eigentlich
existiert ja nur die Gegenwart das ist
das was er mit dem sein meinte die
Gegenwart existiert jetzt aber wenn ich
darüber rede über die Gegenwart ist sie
schon wieder verschlossen ja also
irgendwie ist Zeit was ganz schwer zu
begreifend ist ja sie verfließt einem
nicht nur im Leben sondern auch unter
den Begriffen wenn wir sie begreifen
wollen ist sie schon wieder weg ganz
schwierig die Zeit zu begreifen und das
macht es eben auch schwierig sie auf die
Bildung anzuwenden deswegen möchte ich
jetzt eine andere Unterscheidung bringen
die das ganze ein bisschen klarer macht
und zwar die sogenannten drei Reihen der
Zeit nach John mctargert das ist ein
neuerer Philosoph und ich möchte die mal
ganz kurz erklären weil die glaube ich
uns sehr viel bringen können und
Klarheiten diesen sehr diffusen Zeit
Begriff auch bringen es gibt ja
unterscheidet die Arbeit der Zeit die
bereit der Zeit und die zäherei die
Reihe ist ganz einfach so zu verstehen
dass es hier immer einen jetzt Punkt
gibt das ist die sogenannte subjektive
Zeit es ist ein jetztpunkt von dem aus
gesehen etwas künftig ist und etwas
vergangen ist oh er in diesem Zeitpunkt
kommt noch auf uns zu und ist schon
gewesen arreis also die subjektive Zeit
wie wir sie erleben durch unser
gegenwarts Bewusstsein und zur Zukunft
und vergangenheitsbewusstsein die
B-Reihe hingegen ist eine Reihe wo es
keinen jetztpunkt gibt wo die
Subjektivität keine Rolle spielt das
muss man sich so vorstellen wie so eine
Zeitreihe die vor allem ausgebreitet ist
wo man sagen kann im Jahr 1700 war das
im Jahr 1800 war das und im Jahr 2020
war das das heißt überblicken die Zeit
sind aber selbst nicht wirklich in der
Zeit drin und dann unterscheidet er noch
eine C-Reihe die gar keine zeitliche
Richtung mehr hat sondern das sind nur
die Ereignisse die in einer urologischen
Relation zueinander stehen nämlich
vor n und O ist nach ihn aber jetzt
nicht im zeitlichen Sinne einfach in
diese Ordnung ist und geben von ihm und
oh das ist als eine dialogische Zeit so
kann man sich das vorstellen die keine
wirkliche Richtung aufweisen das habe
ich deswegen verwendet damit wir ein
bisschen Klarheit in die Rede von der
Zeit bekommen Zeit hat als immer
entweder ein subjektiven Charakter dann
geht es um das jetzt und die Gegenwart
die wir erleben oder es geht um so eine
objektive Zeit die wir messen können und
jetzt muss man sich fragen welches
Zeitverständnis ist für die Bildung am
wichtigsten
Zeit hat eine objektiv und eine
subjektive Seite das habe ich schon
gesagt was bedeutet es Zeit lässt sich
objektiv in der Physik zum Beispiel
messen auch in der Chronobiologie da hat
sich ein Betrag den können wir auch
berechnen
im lehren und lernen wenn es jetzt um
die Praxis der Bildung geht ist Zeit
jedoch nicht so sehr ein Objekt welches
außerhalb von uns existiert so wie ein
bestimmter Gegenstand der vor uns steht
wir haben das in dieser diesen Vortrag
vorhin gehört der Student in dem
lernbunker der hat einen ganz
subjektives Zeit empfinden gehabt und
das war für ihn wichtig für seinen
Lehren und Lernen die Objektive Zeit war
was völlig anderes also da müssen wir
schon auf jeden Fall unterscheiden wir
sind also immer schon in der Zeit wenn
wir lehren oder lernen und wir stehen
nicht außerhalb der Zeit also diese
Arbeit betrifft uns das sehr und nicht
diese Beere wo wir gewisse Maße von
außen auf uns schauen diesen Außenblick
haben wir im leeren und lernen in der
Bildung einfach nicht im Gegenteil wenn
wir den Außenblick auf uns werfen würden
so meine These dann könnten wir keine
wirkliche Bildung durchlaufen dann
könnten wir nicht richtig lernen und
lernen dieses subjektive Zeit Qualität
ist sehr wichtig und jetzt kann man sich
fragen wie verhalten sich die Version
der Zeit Vergangenheit Gegenwart und
Zukunft in der Bildung im Prozess der
Bildung zueinander
es gibt jetzt mehrere Möglichkeiten wie
wir in der Zeit stehen also bezogen auf
die Arbeit der Zeit die möchte ich jetzt
im Folgenden vor allem betrachten
entweder die Zeit kommt auf uns zu und
läuft gewissermaßen durch und sind durch
so redet man manchmal die Zeit rennt die
altauf uns zu die Gegenwart nähert sich
uns und Verschwinden der Vergangenheit
oder es gibt eine andere Vorstellung die
ist genau entgegengerichtet wir bewegen
uns in die Zukunft hinein und lassen die
Gegenwart immer wieder aufs Neue hinter
uns da wir rasen in die Zukunft das sind
zwei gegenläufige Bewegungen des
Problems ist jetzt das ist natürlich
eine Metaphorik der Verräumlichung ja
wir verstehen hier Zeit wie ein Raum in
dem wir uns bewegen und das muss man
kritisch hinterfragen tun werden wieder
Zeit der Zeitlichkeit gerecht wenn wir
sie verräumlichen Gegenstände
ich glaube wir müssen hier aufpassen und
deswegen möchte ich jetzt hier ein
alternatives Verständnis der Zeit fürs
Verständnis der Bildung vorschlagen wir
müssen zwischen einem quantitativen
Zeitverständnis und einem qualitativen
Zeitverständnis unterscheiden
quantitativ heißt wir können sie messen
objektivieren auch verräumlichen für
gegenständlichen und qualitatives
Zeitverständnis ist eher die
subjektiveseite die sie im Sinne der
erfüllten Zeit also wie wie wird die
Zeit genutzt wie wird sie
erfahren
dem entspricht auch ein Verständnis von
Sukzession der Zeit also die Zeit die
gleichmäßig verläuft mehr oder weniger
gleichmäßig und ein Verständnis von Zeit
ihr im Sinne der Evolution also wo sich
etwas entwickelt wo sich etwas fast
schon organisch gestaltet und auf dieses
organische Verständnis möchte ich jetzt
ein bisschen weiter eingehen ein
quantitativ nur qualitativ sukzessives
Verständnis der Zeit wird der Bildung
nicht gerecht zu meine These Bildung
setzt also ein qualitatives und
evolutionäres Zeitverständnis voraus und
sie setzt in letzter Hinsicht auch ein
organisches Zeitverständnis voraus was
heißt das jetzt genau ein organisches
Zeitverständnis da möchte ich mich jetzt
wieder auf einen Philosophen beziehen
auf den Philosophen das ist ein
französischer Philosoph der der
sogenannten Phänomenologie
zugehörig ist die Phänomenologie
betrachtet immer wie wir subjektiv Dinge
erfahren also da ist die Erfahrung die
die phänomenale Seite ist hier ganz
wichtig und er hat eine Phänomenologie
des Zeit Empfindens entwickelt und die
finde ich sehr sehr interessant gerade
auf die Frage nach der Bildung er macht
es am Beispiel des Hörens einer Melodie
fest er sagt im höheren einer Melodie
folgen die Töne der Melodie nicht
sukzessiv aufeinander sondern sie
verschmelzen organisch miteinander also
er ist betrachtet jetzt die Zeit aus der
subjektiven Sicht des Zeitempfindens er
sagt wir nehmen die Melodie nicht
nacheinander die Töne der Melodie nicht
nacheinander war sondern ineinander das
ist ganz interessant es ist verschachtel
Zacke und mit diesem ineinander möchte
er zeigen dass es miteinander
zusammenhängt die Töne sind nicht
separat für sich wahrgenommen sondern
sie verweisen aufeinander sie weißen
verweisen zurück und sie verweisen auch
irgendwie nach vorne das kann man schön
in der Musik zeigen dass es hier eine
Dynamik gibt die sich organisch zeigt
er nennt diese innere Dauer eine
qualitative Mannigfaltigkeit die mit der
Zahl also mit der numerischen
physikalischen mathematischen Auffassung
von Zeit nichts mehr zu tun hat keine
Ähnlichkeit hat er spricht von einer
organischen Entwicklung die ihr doch
keine wachsende Quantität ist also Zeit
wird nicht einfach aufeinander addiert
sondern sie entwickelt sich dynamisch
und organisch jetzt müssen wir das
natürlich ein bisschen genauer
betrachten was heißt jetzt das
organische hier möchte ich jetzt die
Frage nach der Bildung aufwerfen und
hier wieder bezugnehmen auf einen
wichtigen denken nämlich Wilhelm von
Humbold der ist ja einer der Klassiker
der Bildungstheorien er sagt Bildung ist
die organische Evolution der
Persönlichkeit also für ihn spielt das
organische bei der Bildung auch eine
große Rolle und der unterscheidet die
Bildung von der bloßen Ausbildung das
meint folgendes die Ausbildung ist auch
zeitlich Gericht auf ein ganz klaren
Ziel hin also auf einer ganz klaren
Zweck und damit ist dann die Bild die
Ausbildung abgeschlossen man kann was
Neues beginnen und davon grenzt sich
Humboldt in seinem Bildungsverständnis
Abbildung ist für ihn ein nie endender
Prozess das ist natürlich ein großes
idealistische Theorie das muss natürlich
auch sagen der heutigen Zeit braucht man
natürlich auch
ausgebildete Menschen aber Ausbildungen
und Bildung widersprechen sich nicht im
Gegensatz sie stärken sich Bildung hat
jetzt im Gegensatz zur Ausbildung keinen
wirklichen zeitlichen Anfang und vor
allem kein zeitliches Ende Bildung ist
wie meine menschliche lebensfarbene
Weise zu existierende Weise zu leben
dass wir eben Leben um uns immer auch zu
bilden und deswegen ist Bildung auch
nach Humboldt eine Form von menschliche
Freiheit also wir bestimmen uns selbst
wir sind darin autonom wir wachsen wir
erweitern uns und das unterscheidet
Bildung von der Ausbildung jetzt möchte
ich abschließenden Ausblick geben auf
die Frage wie können wir jetzt diese
sehr idealistischen sehr vielleicht auch
ein bisschen abstrakten Konzepte von
Zeit und Bildung auf die Hochschullehre
und diese hier geht in diesem
symposition anwenden also wie sieht die
konkrete Anwendung aus ich denke was wir
mitnehmen können ist Lehren und Lernen
nicht als Sukzession zu verstehen
sondern als Evolution
Lehren und Lernen ist nichts additives
was einander gereiht wird sondern etwas
was verbunden ist und die Verbindung ist
nicht nur die Addition die Sukzession
das ist die Grundstruktur aber es geht
hier um die Vernetzung die
Vernetzung das heißt Vernetzung ist
nicht immer in der Sukzession zu
verstehen sondern Vernetzung geht in
ganz verschiedene Richtungen nicht nur
im Sinne dieses Zeitstrahls ja wenn wir
also versuchen Zeit in der Bildung nicht
als Sukzession sondern als Vernetzung zu
verstehen dann glaube ich werden wir
diesen humbolischen Bildungsideal sehr
gerecht warum weil Vernetzung immer ein
unabschließbarer Prozess ist ja wir
können prinzipiell unser Wissen und
unsere
feststand mit ganz anderen Dingen
vernetzen wird lassen uns anregen und
dieses Netz ist permanent erweiterbar
das ist nie abgeschlossen das zeigt
diese netzmetapol glaube ich sehr gut
und ein Ausblick ist natürlich das sind
die neuen Medien die neuen Medien
erlauben uns sehr sehr gut unser Wissen
zu vernetzen hier ist eben ein Beispiel
des Internet man kann dieses Internet
wunderbar nutzen um auch dieser
zeitlichen Dimension der Evolution im
organischen Zeitverständnis zu
entsprechen in unserer Bildung und das
bedeutet im letzten Hinsicht auch dass
wir lehren und lernen immer mehr
vernetzen können also dass wir lehren
und lehren nicht getrennt voneinander
unbedingt verstehen sind das beide in
einen großen Bildungsprozess als Momente
mit einfließen die immer mehr
miteinander vernetzt werden ja das ist
nur ein
utopischer Ausblick aus philosophische
Perspektive ich bedanke mich für die
Aufmerksamkeit und bin gespannt auf die
Diskussion